So let's learn about classification.
Here is the plan.
I'm going to tell you just enough, so
that you can put together a very simple,
but very important type of classifier,
called the logistic classifier.
With that, you'll be able to run through
the first assignment which will have you
download and pre-process some images for
classification.
And then run an actual logistic
classifier on that data.
Once you've connected the bit of math
that's coming up and the code in
that first assignment, everything else
will just be building up from there.
We will be building together all of
the pruning on top of this piece,
block by block.